ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata prima di iniziare però
con questa ricetta velo invitarvi a
mettere un like perché figli di fatto
comunque oggi faremo una ricetta ragazzi
che non vedevo l'ora di fare sto
parlando degli spiedini di cioccolato
possiamo far vedere delle immagini un
attimo di repertorio degli stili
cioccolato mentre vengono aperti e
filano giusto per far capire in che
direzione stiamo andando comunque bando
alle ciance mostriamo subito gli
ingredienti per fare gli speedy in
cioccolato avremmo bisogno 400 g di
showcolate e 400 grammi di dimenticato
la panna 240 ml di un cucchiaino di
estratto di vaniglia 100 g di zucchero
140 grammi di farina 00 160 grammi di
farina un pizzico di salto tre
cucchiaini di lievito in polvere olio
per friggere na cifra it e gattini che
valgono un like innanzi intendo
sciacquate nel magnoni volta è toccato
un gatto per prima cosa e prendo una
ciotola ma aggiungo il cioccolato lo
specchietto grossolanamente aggiungo la
panna no no no cosa che devo fare lo
dovevi fare del microonde il cioccolato
ma con la panna
no no gianmarco non mi sta ascoltando
dove guidare io sì che ne so che tu gli
pazzini che con 4 secondi
comunque questo
siglato cioccolata ma la palla non
mettete la panna riscaldato al microonde
ma cosa c'era fondi occulto mettete un
like perché gattini mettete un like per
questo gattino chiaro oggi i geni dopo
un minuto e stiamo così facciamo un
altro meno tiro di microonde anche
importantissimo se vuoi li fate e non mi
pagate su instagram che vengo a cerca
casa cioè questo qui è una di quelle
ricette che se vieni dovete farlo io
aggiungere la panna con dimenticato
adesso dovrebbe venire un bel composto
per poi versare ecco come dovrebbe
venire gattini mettete un troppo lì non
è molto liquida cosi le due si soccorre
il mandato gianmarco ho messo le doti
che mi sono state indicate da questo
punto blu tolte di trent'anni del
microonde nel frattempo gioco un altro
po di cioccolato orgasmo visivo questo
qui pornografico per quanto riguarda
questo qui è un contenuto da segnalare
prendiamo un contenitore moderiamo
questo contenitore con della carta da
forno
l'altrove rava è un risultato discreto
normative direi soddisfacenti battiamo
a questo punto infiliamo in frigo per 2
ore prendiamo questa densi passate le 2
ore prima di tirar fuori la teglia dal
frigo mettiamoci a fare la pastella
vi spiego nel gran cosa aprite due uova
e le mettere all'interno di una ciotola
pazzeschi aggiungiamo il latte un
cucchiaino di estratto di vaniglia
a occhio e mischiamo tutto quanto
[Musica]
aggiungiamo lo zucchero è facilissima
farina e la farina di mais come mais
pizzico di sale e chagall a cannes
mettete da parte passate due ore andiamo
a vedere che cosa è successo a questo
cosa ci ha messo i secoli e possiamo
dire che pensavo che non si sarebbe mai
mai rappreso ora è una cenetta se lo
fate a casa e vedete che ci mette i
secoli non temete perché dopo due ore
succede questo fidatevi di me le persone
del taglio stendiamo della carta forno
prendiamo a questo punto di carmelo
mettiamo sopra come se fosse patinata
che scemo avrei dovuto fare questo
momento della verità e ricoh oggi sul
tagliere esito negativo
[Musica]
dico senza ride cospargiamo subito sopra
con il cacao o fallito però ci veloce a
testa alta stuzzicadenti
non sono mai stato così vivo senza
sembra terribile mi sembra non li avrò
bollicine se tu mi sorprende perché ti
allo spiedo più o meno tiro su un cross
perfetto allo spiedo a questo punto
dobbiamo passare all'azione versiamo il
composto non ci prende niente con quello
infiliamo dentro
ecco cosa abbiamo completamente fallito
no no frigo per un'altra ora questa e
trapeze dobbiamo trovare il modo il
tramite del profilo e attendo voleva
vedere che è molto più forte il free da
enrico per il semplice fatto che non
puoi farlo veneti no dai è rotto
salviamo la situazione aggiungo del
latte spegniamo con un secondo le luci
ho bisogno di energia era da tempo che
non si fa arriva così tanto poi ha reso
poco solido quello che doveva essere un
solido e solido che doveva essere io ho
seguito alla lettera tutto quello che
stupefacenti da lucera tesi la riaccendo
subito adesso però parliamo ma non si
può abbonare ho preso una parte vicenza
qui è dove quello prima di me già ci ha
lasciato la mano poi diffusore così si
faccia felici
[Musica]
sono arya stark ma c'era qualcosa che ti
ho cercato anche di scongelarlo ma non
si riesce a scorgere il terrore potrà
spegnere tutto quanto ma io ho vissuto
più facile estrema stata la roccia
avviene 18 ai re d'inghilterra paris e
vola
cogli dinamiche non ti voglio venire
dopo il pacco lo so
cercando di fare quello proviamo spinge
a dire una cosa
prego 40 minuti dopo abbiamo un frullato
la pastella abbiamo accoltellato e
fondato il freezer ne ho messo di nuovo
col nel dolore dentro un posto più
freddo vediamo se tutto questo ci
porterà a dei risultati soddisfacenti
altrimenti userò quello stesso coltello
per farlo io quelli che fanno queste
ricette che tu vedi su instagram come
ritirate fuori queste ricette perfette
non c'era verità non ci dite le cose
come stanno ci stanno in fila
giro giro giro gino maio si sta
sciogliendo abbiate brodino caldo che
sta stritolando la sua parata d'alba ma
davvero un errore alla lista è in dubbio
commenta da solo ma vedi quello che è
rimasto chiuso sta tenendo bene
facciamoli new scortiamo riuscirci ha
fatto per farla così non si vedeva
neanche mi ricordo da quali genti forse
è troppo liquido sembra un girone
dantesco che si sfalda farne uscito
mezzo non si farà l'assaggio oggi vorrei
che tutte le persone però mettano un
like perché ci abbiamo provato ci
abbiamo provato fino alla fine abbiamo
picco lato abbiamo fatto qualsiasi cosa
abbiamo suonato non ha funzionato il
lavoro ha funzionato sì ma non faremo il
suo passaggio e che vuole dire una
celebrazione di una ricetta qui è un
funerale
io assaggerà in silenzio silenzio
scriveteci un qualcosa per non farci
abbandonare perché oggi vedo nero e
vorrei chiudere il canale assaggiamo
questa pietanza inguardabile conto di
dati aspetto è vicino in classifica va
benissimo
buonissimo marinare mi ha fatto di dire
il vero peccato perché a buonissimo e
anche che il filmato questa bella parte
da assaggiare
sì sì sì ma comunque non sa mangiare
mangia sempre coi denti si è vero alcune
persone lucide credito a fastidio
rimangia rimangia rimangio vaina se ne
lancia lega è buonissimo quanto poi 10
euro e stato bellissimo stare insieme
tutti quanti a fare una ricetta
indimenticabile in questa nuova
settimana se vi è piaciuto di più
iscriviti che questo canale attivate la
campagna
la delle notifiche e mettete mi
raccomando un pollice giù ma al
contrario e soprattutto fateci sapere in
che modo ci vediamo la prossima
settimana forse proprio in questo
momento un momento in cui io mi sento
che sta toccando il fondo forse proprio
adesso invece si volerà verso il cielo
quest'anno delle ricette più basse del
format se non abbiamo mai scavato più
basso sia la prossima ciao